controversy continues to swirl around
Alabama's new abortion restrictions Iran
continues to provoke the West and two
new Democratic candidates enter the race
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
Wow it is a busy busy news day we have a
lot to get to and I have some I think
interesting analysis of where the
abortion controversy those from here but
first losing your hair sucks okay male
pattern baldness runs in my family two
out of three dudes will experience hair
loss by the time they are 35 introducing
keeps the easiest and most affordable
way to keep the hair you have these FDA
products approved products used to cost
so much but now thanks to keeps they're
finally inexpensive and easy to get for
five minutes now starting at just ten
bucks every month you will never have to
worry about hair loss again getting
started with keeps is really easy
sign up takes less than five minutes
just answer a few questions snap some
photos of your hair a licensed physician
will review your information online and
then recommend the right treatment for
you then it is shipped directly to your
door every three months keeps offers
generic versions and the only two FDA
approved hair loss products out there
some of you probably tried them before
we've probably never gotten them for
this price keeps his only ten bucks to
35 bucks a month plus now you can get
your first month for free which is a
hell of a deal for getting to keep your
hair not to receive your first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm
slash pen that is ke EPS calm / pen free
month of treatment at keeps calm / pen
go check them out right now keeps hair
today
hair tomorrow again that's ke EPS calm /
pen and get that first month of
treatment for free go check it out right
this very instant okay so the obvious
controversy of the day continues to be
this Alabama law and there are other
states that are now pushing for new
restrictions on abortion which on a
moral level is fantastic because
obviously in the view of pro lifers
everywhere abortion is the grave moral
sin that threatens the soul of our
nation it has been so ever since Roe vs.
Wade the notion that a woman has a
rights to kill a human life within her
with the help of her doctor is not
written anywhere in the Constitution it
is nor in the Declaration of
Independence folks who are making the
argument that abortion is a woman's
right
are doing so based on the absolute
nonsensical case of Roe vs. Wade we
explained yesterday all the details of
Roe versus Wade the emanations from the
penumbra's the idea that everyone gets
to define what human life is of their
own accord which of course is sheer
nonsense if that that logic taken to its
ultimate conclusion allows you to
dehumanize anybody that you wish to
victimize for your own particular
purposes and unfortunately that really
is what
Horsham is on a broad scale on a broad
scale the attempt to prevent the
understanding that human life exists in
the womb for the sake of convenience has
become part of a rote thought process by
which feminists claim that abortion is
nothing more than the dismissal of a
polyp the removal of a polyp that's
utter sheer nonsense it is deceptive
nonsense at that and it is morally
dangerous nonsense as well so on a pure
moral level an attempt to bar abortion
is not just in attempts to protect the
life of the unborn it's an attempt to
protect the soul of a country that seeks
to prevent the loss of that life and you
don't have a right to abortion you do
have a right life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness from the
Declaration of Independence is the way
that it's expressed in the Constitution
of the United States both the fifth and
the Fourteenth Amendments which
ironically and perversely have been used
as an excuse for abortion by the Supreme
Court it is both the fifth and the
Fourteenth Amendments that say that life
cannot be removed without due process of
law this is a human life in the womb and
all the counter arguments that are
currently being used that it's a polyp
nonsense that human life is is
arbitrarily defined nonsense everyone
knows that human life begins at
conception now the real question is on a
logical level when does quote-unquote
personhood begin but the truth is that
you don't have to believe that an embryo
is the equivalent of a fully grown baby
on a scientific level to acknowledge
that human life cannot be removed human
life incipient human life as I have
called it that you don't have to argue
that that is the same thing as a 35 year
old man in order for you to argue that
this does have countervailing weight and
that that embryo does have in fact a
right to life under the Constitution of
the United States personhood amendments
are simply designed to extend the notion
of personhood to all human life and it
is a unique human life just the same way
that an unfertilized egg is not a
chicken but a fertilized egg is a
potential chicken okay the fact is that
is a chicken life just the same way a
fertilized human egg would be a human
life that is a human life in a potential
baby right that is the way that the
science works and so the media are up in
arms about this the Democrats are up in
arms about all of this there are several
other states that are now considering
similar laws Missouri has enact
it's called the scan for the unborn act
it would ban abortion as soon as the
doctor can detect heart or brain
activity in the embryo which is
basically the equivalent of the Georgia
heartbeat bill the Alabama bill is a
little stronger it says from moment of
conception there can be no abortion the
missouri bill and the georgia bill are
effectively heartbeat bills the bill
includes alternative language to deal
with the possibility that such an early
ban could be ruled unconstitutional if
that happens it becomes a 14 week ban
and if that cutoff date is deemed
unconstitutional it becomes an 18 week
ban and then if necessary a 20-week ban
the legislation also prohibits minors
from obtaining an abortion without
written parental consent in most cases
which again make sense considering that
if you are in school and you want an
aspirin you need permission from your
parents but if you're in school and you
need an abortion then presumably you
don't have to ask your parents one
that's that's ridiculous
Louisiana also is pushing a fetal
heartbeat bill and the measure which
Governor John bel Edwards who's a
Democrat has already indicated he would
sign seeks to prohibit the abortion of
an unborn human being with a detectable
heartbeat the ban would only take effect
if a federal appeals court upholds
similar legislation in Mississippi that
legislation was signed into law in March
the Louisiana bills authors a Democrat
named John milkovisch he's repeatedly
cited his religious beliefs in pushing
the legislation 40 says God values human
life so do the people of Louisiana
that's not really a religious argument
that's basically just an argument that
human life ought to be valued and human
life begins at conception as every
science book that you have ever read
says that it does the Michigan
Legislature also passed a bill on
Tuesday outlawing an abortion procedure
commonly used during the second
trimester the dilation and evacuation
procedure in which a doctor dilates the
patient's cervix and then removes the
fetus with suction and medical tools
like forceps essentially cuts apart the
baby in the womb and then sucks it out
into a sink to outlaw that procedure
seems perfectly reasonable yeah an all
of this is an attempt to protect human
life now but the left wishes to say is
that this is an attempt to control
women's bodies this has always been a
very weird argument to me I don't
understand why this has anything to do
with quote-unquote control of a woman's
body when it is clearly attempting to
protect a separate body that of the
fetus from the ravages of an abortion
doctor I understand that this fetus
happens to be in the woman's body but if
men wanted to control women's bodies do
you think they'd really start with the
uterus
the uterus that men are really
interested in evil sexist men evil
patriarchal men what they are really
interested in is controlling your uterus
or is that they have an actress such
it's such a straw man ridiculous
argument that men are in trauma sue
there are lots of other parts of women
that most men are interested in the
uterus comes like way way way down on
the list what most people are interested
in male and female is controlling what
happens to the human life inside the
womb and this notion that the left has
been pushing out that true women are
pro-abortion absolute crap the fact is a
huge number of women are pro-life a huge
number of women in South Carolina women
while registered voters outnumber men by
some 300,000 people South Carolina is an
incredibly pro-life state governor kiv
in Alabama is in fact a Republican and
she's and she signed the bill yesterday
she was asked a question about it by CBS
it didn't go well for the CBS reporter
all human life is precious where's the
money coming from the support people who
aren't ready to be mothers or aren't
financially stable to take care of a
child
you simply cannot defer protecting the
lives of unborn children because of cost
okay of course that is a hundred percent
true this argument which seems to be
used by the left so often this economic
argument that your life is more better
than more better your life is more
successful economically if you abort
babies and therefore it's okay to abort
babies is a sick argument a deeply sick
argument if your argument is that you
can do anything that forwards you
economically including the killing of
another human life man it doesn't get
much worse than that and that that
argument by Liz plank the fabulous
feminist feminist AB you list over at
twitter.com behind millions of
successful men is an abortion they don't
regret getting with their partner I urge
men to go beyond solidarity and talk
about how they've personally benefited
from abortion rights to not because it's
the right thing for it and not because
it's the right thing for you to do but
because it's true and I'm amazed that
feminists who five minutes ago we're
saying that men have nothing to say
about abortion now are saying men need
to stand up for abortion because they've
benefited economically from their
partners aborting baby by the way
nothing as scummy as a man who says yes
I've economically benefited from my from
the killing of my unborn child
I'm so glad that my female sex partner
decided to do away with it that sound
like a guy that you want to marry ladies
that sound like a dude you want to bring
home to mother I'm so glad she had an
abortion it's really made me some more
success more hours at the office and
that's been great sound it sounds like a
delightful delightful fellow now what's
what's fascinating about all of this is
that in New York just a few months back
the New York legislature passed a
Legislature passed a bill that
effectively legalizes abortion for any
reason up till point of birth it is a
insanely radical bill obviously and the
media didn't cover it that way the media
covered it is well this is reasonable is
that the right went crazy the left
suggested no this is totally utterly
reasonable listen we're not putting our
priorities on you this is New York
hey Alabama passes a bill and
Mississippi passes a bill and Georgia
passes a bill in Louisiana is about to
pass a bill Missouri is about to pass a
bill and suddenly it's no no no this is
a national attack on women really it's a
state it's a state decision about
abortion rights so-called abortion
rights right these are state legislative
actions now what's fascinating is that
it's the left that has insisted on
nationalizing the issue through rule vs.
way now I think that the right should
nationalize the issue by the way I'm in
favor of a constitutional amendment to
protect life but that is likely not
going to happen anytime soon which means
that effectively speaking it is a
federal issue
it's a federalist issue meaning that
each state gets to make its own decision
if roe v wade were to disappear tomorrow
New York is not going to start outlawing
abortions under the Constitution of the
United States it would take a
constitutional amendment in order to
change the law with regard to all of
this sort of stuff what's amazing is
Democrats suddenly suggesting that if
Alabama passes a law that it's a
national issue we'll talk about it in
just one second first let's talk about
your sleep quality you know I'm on the
road today that means I didn't sleep as
well as I normally do why because when
I'm at home I get to sleep on a helix
sleep mattress my helix sleep mattress
is just fantastic helix
sleep has a quiz it takes two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you whether you're a side
sleeper or a hot sleeper
whether you like a plush or firm bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising hulex leap is rated
the number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine
CNN called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just go
to helix sleep calm
take there two minutes leap quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life four couples helix can even
split two mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights at risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you probably will
helix is offering up to 125 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
their mattresses are so good that my
wife and I ordered one we got rid of a
more expensive mattress because this
mattress is indeed so comfortable so
good I got one for my sister for her
wedding as well go check out helix sleep
comm / Ben from - 125 bucks off your
mattress order helix leap comm / Ben go
check them out right now so Democrats
are claiming that these Alabama laws are
attempting to quote unquote overturn the
will of the majority where in Alabama
where this was voted for overwhelmingly
by the legislators Tom Perez head of the
DNC right has been attempting to
overturn the will of the majority 70% of
American people say very clearly Roe vs.
Wade is the law of the land and leave
these decisions up to women up to
families it's a very personal decision I
don't pretend to be able to step in the
shoes of somebody in that circumstance
and we shouldn't try to step in the
shoes of someone in their circle long to
say okay well again we shouldn't try to
step into the shoes of someone in that
circumstance well we should if we're
protecting a human life you do not get
to arbitrarily define human life every
grave evil in human history has
basically been based on the notion you
get to arbitrarily define away life to
meet your vision of what the world
should be it's deeply deeply dangerous
stuff Tom Perez didn't stop with his
silliness there he then all suggested we
have to organize in all 50 states to
save Roe versus Wade again this makes no
sense Roe vs. Wade is a Supreme Court
decision it doesn't matter what you
organize in any state it is a Supreme
Court decision Roe vs. Wade this is like
saying we need to organize in all 50
states to overturn obergefell well you
can't
it's a Supreme Court decision unless you
are looking for a constitutional
amendment to to protect the killing of
the unborn I don't see Tom Perez calling
for that at this point the mission of
the Democratic National Committee is to
elect Democrats up and down the ballot
and this
unconscionable activity in Alabama is a
stark reminder of the fact that we must
continue to organize in all 50 states I
believe we can win in places and and we
can win everywhere we demonstrated that
in 2018 and we're going to continue to
organize everywhere because things that
people thought were just well settled
yep in the world of Trump are no longer
well settled and and this is exhibit a
Exhibit A okay fine Chuck Todd then
makes the point on NBC that it's culture
Wars holding Republicans together that's
the real reason that Republicans care
about all of this is because of the
supposed culture Wars not because they
actually care about abortion which by
the way is the number one animating
issue for a huge swath of Republicans I
spoke at the March for Life
three-quarters of a million people
showed up they do every year
hey but Chuck Cod Chuck Todd says no no
this is all just you know it's just
political pandering by Republicans you
know as opposed to Democrats who who say
you should be able to kill a baby while
it's in the birth canal according to
Kathy Kathy Tran Virginia delegate in
the House of Delegates here's Chuck Todd
making the argument it just it's just
cultural war stuff guys the pro-life
movements mission to get roe v-- wade in
front of this conservative Supreme Court
is a bigger deal and the president's
escalating embrace of the culture wars
is perhaps the biggest deal of them all
because right now the culture wars are
this glue that holds the Republican
Party together Republicans are divided
on issues like immigration tariffs and
health care as matters of policy the
president hasn't made those issues
referendums on policy so much as he's
made them flashpoints in a larger
culture battle with immigrants it's
about what does America look like with
the Chinese with socialists you name it
you get the picture and in a way he's
made the GOP into a culture of Trump
okay so this idea that it's Republicans
engaged in a culture war but not
Democrats is just silly a culture war
requires two sides it is Democrats who
have been pushing to legalize abortion
all the way to points of birth and
Republicans who are pushing back against
that by saying we want to ban abortion
from point of conception now this does
raise a strategic question it was
interesting Pat Robertson who obviously
is extremely pro-life he came out
yesterday he said that he thinks the
Alabama abortion law goes too far he was
on the 700 club talking about this I
think Obama has gone too far
they've passed a law that would give a
99 year prison sentence the people who
commit abortion there's no exception for
rape or incest it's an extreme law and
that they want it challenged Roe vs.
Wade but my humble view is that this is
not the case we want to bring to the
Supreme Court because I think this one
who lose okay so the the point that
Robertson is making here people are
jumping all over Robertson because
they're suggesting well he's given up
his pro-life bonafide he's I think that
there is a good interesting argument to
be had about whether the Alabama law for
example is a law that is designed to
achieve its purpose what I mean by this
is I've said all along it's a moral law
I think it is a moral law to protect
human life all the way back to
conception for all reasons it is
important to protect human life human
life is either worth protecting
or it is not worth protecting and if you
say that it is not worth protecting
you're going to have to explain why
certain types of human life are not
worth protecting you're gonna have to
make a logical argument for that hey but
that's a different question from the
strategy that should be adopted by the
pro-life movement in pursuing the
abolition of abortion so to make an
analogy back before the Civil War there
are two positions on the abolition of
slavery everyone who is in the
Republican Party at that time what was
was it or the vast majority of the
Republican Party was built around the
idea that that slavery should be
abolished but there were two different
approaches that were essentially being
pushed approach number one was the
William Lloyd Garrison approach which
was okay if we got to go to war let's go
to war we got to abolish it across the
country let's do it right now it has to
be done right this very instant and
William Lloyd Garrison was an
extraordinarily polarizing figure
specifically because of that now you
needed that you needed William Lloyd
Garrison speaking out on behalf of
slaves speaking out about the evils of
slavery
it required a constant public relations
battle from people like Frederick
Douglas and William Lloyd Garrison and
people who are stark abolitionists and
then it required the political ingenuity
of Abraham Lincoln in order to achieve
the end of slavery and if you look at
Lincoln's progress in achieving the end
of slavery when the civil war breaks out
basically it is the South that's éclairs
war the South declares war because they
think that Lincoln is going to abolish
slavery Lincoln is going around saying
no no no no I'm not interested in
abolishing slavery
I just want the preservation of the
Union even when he issues the
Emancipation Proclamation the
Emancipation Proclamation only applies
to states that he does not control as of
yet right it only applies to to the
states that were part of the Confederacy
the Emancipation Proclamation and even
then he makes many public statements
about how he said against integration
how he's against all sorts of civil
rights for black folks now does that
mean that Lincoln was morally right uh
no no he's morally wrong on all of those
points but the fact is that Lincoln had
to bring the American people alone
gradually so the question here is
incremental ISM and what is effective
versus the stark position now again you
need both in the public conversation the
question is whether these pieces of
legislation are actually going to be
effective in achieving the goal of
pushing that pushing back the line as to
what is acceptable under American law
and by the Supreme Court in terms of the
pro-life position so the two opposite
sides of this position that the the
Alabama bill is a good idea and that the
Alabama bill is a bad idea on a tactical
level not in a moral level these are
presented by Rama Spooner over at
Bloomberg on the one hand and David
French on the other at National Review
so David who's been on the radio show
good friend he argues that Alabama and
Georgia are doing the right thing by
passing these these very strict pro-life
laws and he says it's time to throw down
the gauntlet it's time to test this
thing up at the Supreme Court level he
says both Alabama's abortion ban and
Georgia's heartbeat law contain a key
provision they declared the personhood
of the unborn child this is a vital
measure that has aimed directly at a key
portion of the Roe versus Wade opinion
late last week I had a lengthy phone
conversation with state representative
ed Setzler sponsor of Georgia's
legislation he said his bill wasn't
waving its fist at Roe it's answering
Roe specifically he pointed at a
provision in part 9 of justice
Blackmun's opinion where Blackman states
that if the personhood of the baby is
established then the pro-abortion case
collapses the late Supreme Court justice
was of course discussing the definition
of personhood under the Federal
Constitution sets lore however notes
that the Supreme Court doctrine has long
allowed States to expand constitutional
liberties they can establish standards
of religious free freedom free speech or
due process for example that go beyond
the first and Fifth Amendment's they
cannot be more restrictive than the
federal constitution in the abortion
context this doctrine traditionally has
been interpreted to allow states like
New York to
TEKT abortion rights beyond the minimal
threshold required by Roe and Planned
Parenthood versus Casey Georgia and
potentially Alabama would be asking the
court to permit them to expand the
constitutional liberty of the unborn
child and to recognize the distinct
human identity of the baby in the womb
in other words Georgia and Alabama are
saying we've read Roe and we're making
the very legal statement that justice
Blackmun says would fundamentally
undermine the case for abortion under
our federal system we can expand the
legal definition of life he says while
pro-life Americans can and do engage in
good faith debates about tactics I
prefer the most direct approach tell the
court what life means make the court
break the federal system once again he
says the timing is right it's time for
the court to rule on Rose and we know
where we stand he says if the court
overturns Roe rightfully holding that
the Federal Constitution is silence on
abortion the battle turns to the states
if row is upheld and the legal battle
over abortion is reduced both now and
for the foreseeable future if too far
more marginal issues like admitting
privileges or clinic regulations or late
term abortion bans pro-life Americans
would understand that presidents and
judges have treated them like Lucy with
the football inducing them to vote on
the issue that is more important to them
than any other only to protect the
status quo he says I know that in theory
the judges could overrule Roe through
say in admitting-privileges case but why
would that in why would they instead we
have to challenge Roe so that is
prospective number one it's time to
challenge Roe now is the time if we
don't do it now when are we going to do
it that's the case David French is
making then there is the other
perspective Amana gets you that in just
a second as to the tactical usefulness
of what Alabama and Georgia are doing
first
I love the Dollar Shave Club has
everything I need to look feel and smell
my best but I love even more is the fact
I never have to go to a store that's
because first GSE delivers everything I
need directly to my door - they keep me
fully stocked on what I use so I don't
run out here's how it works
Valerie shaved Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for they have you covered
head to toe for your hair your skin your
face you name it they've got it and they
have this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use you determine what you
want and when you want it and it shows
up right at your door from once a month
to once every six months that's what I
do for there amber lavender body
cleanser my goodness it smells
delightful and it is calming I mean do I
seem like a person who needs calm you
are correct I do and that's why I use
the amber lavender body cleanser from
Dollar Shave Club plus with their
handsome discount the more you buy the
more you save and right now they've got
a bunch of starter sets you can try for
just five bucks like their oral care kit
after that the restock
ships regular size products at regular
price so what in hell are you waiting
for get your starter set for just 5
bucks right now at dollarshaveclub.com /
Ben that is dollarshaveclub.com / Ben
again they've got those starter sets you
can try for just 5 bucks and then keep
the regular size products coming at
regular price dollarshaveclub.com / Ben
go check it out right now so as I say
there are two perspectives on the
Georgia and Alabama law from the
pro-life perspective and again I agree
with everything morally in the Alabama
law down to the marrow of it the
question is whether it's going to be
effective so David French says well you
know Roe exists this will be elevated to
the Supreme Court the Supreme Court will
rule and then we'll know where we stand
that's prospective number one go for a
go-for-broke push it as hard as you can
William Lloyd Garrison then there is the
Lincoln incrementalist approach you know
and again it's not that Lincoln was in
favor of preserving slavery it was that
Lincoln saw a strategic value to
gradually and incrementally bringing the
American people there this is the
approach ramas proneural is pushing over
at bloomberg.com
and that person with him unfriendly he
says for roughly 25 years the movement
against abortion has been predominantly
incrementalist its focus has been on
restricting abortion in relatively
modest ways rather than amending the
constitution to prohibit it altogether
in the 1990s pro-lifers begins a
campaign to ban a method of abortion
they called partial birth more recently
they have sought to ban abortions after
20 weeks of gestation the theory behind
this strategy is that changes to the law
would reduce abortion rates debate over
these changes would turn public opinion
against abortion small victories today
would enable bigger ones tomorrow that
day has come in the eyes of some pro
lifers and then r amish quotes David
French and preneur says nearly everyone
who's active in the movement agrees with
French that the ultimate goal should be
that as pro-life slogan has it every
child is welcomed in life and protected
in law which requires the overturning of
Roe versus Wade but people who agree on
the goal are divided on how to get there
French is under estimating the practical
advantages of gradual step-by-step
progress it's true as he suggests that
the Supreme Court can allow limited
measures such as 20-week bans without
dismantling its abortion jurisprudence
if it took up a heartbeat bill it would
have to choose either to keep or scrap
its precedents a major pro-life
objective would be in sight but since
heartbeat laws are flatly inconsistent
with the president's the justices might
not have to take them up in the first
place lower courts would strike them
down the justices could merely
to hear appeals it takes four justices
to take a writ of certiorari the
question is whether there are four
justices who would even take up the
heartbeat bills
so right now supposedly there are five
conservative justices in reality there
are three solidly conservative justices
and then there are two who are sorta on
the fence
hey the three who are solidly
conservative would be Thomas Gorsuch and
Alito those are the three who would
probably take up a writ and then you
have Cavanaugh who might not and Roberts
who might not okay that's a it's a bit
of a dangerous game you're passing these
bills they could be struck down at the
court of appeals level and never reach
the Supreme Court as Panora says let's
say though that the case actually were
taken up by the Supreme Court
Frenchy's argument presupposes some
justices are on the fence if so wouldn't
they be less likely to uphold a more
far-reaching abortion restriction than
to uphold the limited one the upholding
of a limited restriction would put
future pro-life litigators in a stronger
position to win more legal ground the
turning back of a more frontal challenge
would put them in a worse one in other
words if you push a full ban on abortion
to the Supreme Court it is easier to
convince Justice Roberts to simply
strike it down and in doing so to
actually create damage okay what I've
been saying is that I think that the
Supreme Court if it's gonna pair back
its abortion rulings is likely to do so
by looking at the undue burden standard
under Planned Parenthood versus case her
there's a tactical consideration again I
agree with the morality of the Alabama
law where I King it would be a
constitutional amendment okay but the
fact is that the Supreme Court is still
going to rule on this stuff and when the
Supreme Court rules on it the most
likely scenario is that they don't
overturn Roe I don't think you have five
votes for that in the most likely
scenario is they don't overturn Planned
Parenthood versus Casey the most likely
scenarios they do what they've been
doing with for example partial birth
abortion bans and what they say is the
undue burden standard allows for women's
who continue to have abortions until a
certain point in pregnancy but science
is showing that we need to move that
standard further and further back the
incrementalist position in other words
is making it harder and harder for a
woman to get an abortion later and that
is the most likely outcome now let's say
you come along with the Alabama bill and
the Supreme Court says no you know what
this disagrees with precedent we're not
looking at it or even worse it gets to
the Supreme Court and the Supreme Court
says you know what we can see you're
fine
in tents here and that means that we are
shoring up the undue burden standard
that we are going to exacerbate the
undue burden standard that in fact what
we are going to try to do is limit
abortion laws even more because we see
that your end goal is not in fact to
allow abortion to a particular point it
is instead to ban abortion utterly you
could easily see Justice Roberts signing
on to an opinion something like that and
that would be significantly damaging to
the pro-life clause let's let's take
another example
so the Missouri law seems to me the best
written of the ones that I have seen the
Missouri law says look we want to stop
abortion at the heartbeat if that
doesn't hold and will stop abortion at
14 weeks 18 weeks 20 weeks and that
gives the Supreme Court the option to
broaden Planned Parenthood versus KC or
to strike down Roe versus Wade entirely
that is a better drawn law what you want
to do is keep fighting on the ground
with which most Americans agree until
you can shift American opinion on this
here's what the opinion polls show and
listen I know when it comes to morality
opinion polls don't matter but they do
when it comes to actually shifting the
law because what you could get is a huge
backlash from the quote unquote moderate
metal who are not convinced fully on the
pro-life cause and who decide that it is
too extreme the Alabama law is too
extreme so let's elect a Democrat so
then the result of the Alabama law will
be that it never goes into effect that a
Democrat is elected president of the
United States the Democrats take over
the Senate or that the Supreme Court
ends up broadening abortion law rather
than restricting abortion law all of
those would be very very bad results
this is why I'm a little bit wary of the
strategy I think that it's coming from
folks or far too sanguine about the
status of the Supreme Court right now
Ramesh Ponnuru tends to agree he says
pro-lifers would consider it morally
obligatory to press for the maximum
feasible legal protection for unborn
children that could be sustained over
time but the risks of a backlash that
setback that protection would be
substantial particularly in some states
at each time and place the pro-life task
will be twofold putting into law those
protections that command to consensus
and working to change that consensus in
the direction of more perfect justice
each stage of this process of democratic
persuasion will require difficult
difficult judgments of what is
achievable this is this is corrected to
me this seems right if you want to stop
abortion you have to look at what can
actually be done spitting in
the wind isn't gonna do you a whole hell
of a lot of good in just a second we're
gonna get to the 2020 race where you see
Democrats immediately jumping on all of
this for their own political game again
that doesn't invalidate the morality for
the thousandth time of the laws that are
being passed it does call into question
the strategy I'll get to that in just
one second first head on over to Daily
wire calm and subscribe right now for
$9.99 a month for $9.99 you get $9.99 a
month you get additional two hours of
the show every single day I mean we are
working hard here for you not only that
but also we have an episode of the
conversation every few weeks we do an
episode of the conversation
unfortunately for you the one today is
with Michael moles but you can still
tune in 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
it's free to watch on Facebook and
YouTube only subscribers can ask the
questions subscribe tune in at 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation please ask Michael why he
is still employed I think every question
should probably be that also when you
subscribe and get the annual you get
this you very greatest in beverage
vessels the leftist years hot or cold
tumblr as I say it is magnificent it is
delicious
you will enjoy it we're on the road and
today I decided I was going to even
activate the D cloaking button here so
you actually can see it but as I've said
before when you're on the road sometimes
it's quote sometimes it's not it does
give you an immense amount of control
also when you subscribe you get our
Sunday specials on Saturday and that
means that you get early this week's
Sunday special starring Carly Fiorina
who stopped by for a chat if we want to
reconnect the social fabric we have to
rebuild relationships in the most
effective way to build relationships is
collaborate with somebody else and solve
a problem don't talk up here in abstract
get down on the ground and solve the
problem
[Music]
okay so go check that out right now
Kylie furin is just terrific and you'll
see the entire hour long conversation
considers it would consider politics and
business and what it's like to be a
powerful female in a world that that
sometimes is not super friendly to that
Carlene I disagree about some of that
stuff but she is just first-rate
and you're gonna really enjoy the
conversation so please go check that out
subscribe leave us a review over at
YouTube or iTunes that always helps us
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so Democrats are attempting to jump into
the fray on this abortion debate and
make hay while the Sun shines
they're doing so in some of the most
dishonest ways I've ever seen well get
to the 20/20 candidates in just a second
first I have to show you how Alexandra
Cosmo Cortez responded to all of this so
the inimitable aoc brilliant brilliant
woman she tweeted out Alabama lawmakers
are making all abortions a felony
punishable with jail time including
women victimized by rape and incest of
course no added punishments for rapists
it's going to Governor K Ivy's desk she
will decide the future of women's rights
in Alabama okay so she's just lying here
the Alabama law does not criminalize the
women okay women who are victimized by
rape and incest - do not go to jail and
when somebody pointed this out AOC then
started to lie Liz wheeler pointed this
out and alc started to lie like a rug
she said actually it would be a felony
for women if those women are medical
providers see according to your own
semantic standard you lied we can fact
check obvious semantics all day and make
absurd bad-faith claims if that's how
you want if you how you want b-but I
have better uses for my time no you
don't then saying silly things hey-oh
see no no no you do that like full time
so just lies right her original tweet is
women or victimized by rape and incest
could go to jail and then when called on
that goes what I meant was female
abortion doctors boom might drop what a
liar she is okay but she's not the only
one who is lying kirsten gillibrand who
is of course one of the foremost
Democratic contenders for zero percent
of the vote
you know let's play some kirsten
gillibrand theme music she's taking
every position on every possible topic
that is true for gun rights and now on
abortion she is taking the position that
Alabama passes a law and somehow that is
a national attack on reproductive
freedom please explain Christine
Gillibrand how states that are not in
New York are passing laws that don't
affect New York and that's a national
attack on reproductive freedom we have
to shine a light on this issue we have
to raise up voices of the women who will
be affected by this draconian and
inhumane policy and make no mistake this
is a nationwide attack on women's
reproductive freedom on their basic
civil rights and basic human rights over
twenty nine states in this year alone
are attacking women's constitutional
rights and we have to fight we have to
fight now harder than we have ever
fought before inspiring stuff from a
woman whose immediate family might vote
for her in a primary so Kirsten
Gillibrand pushing this Cory Booker goes
even further Cory Booker Spartacus as it
were
Cory Booker is such a brave individual
he comes forty cents
I'll even pass a bill legalizing
abortion nationwide so whose
nationalizing the issue now Cory Booker
Alabama passes a law New York passes a
law you say you want New York's a lot of
govern everyone Cory Booker but don't
worry it's only Republicans who want to
nationalize the abortion issue even
though Roe versus Wade nationalized what
had been at that point a state issue
those of us who are running for
president have a chance to affect the
national conversation we are not
helpless in this fight in the face of
extreme and justice we must organize and
we must do the kind of things that New
York did which was some shrining roe v--
wade codifying that in law and we can
actually do that in Congress by passing
a bill that protects women's
reproductive rights and make that the
federal law of the land so it's pretty
amazing again Democrats people like
Chuck Todd saying that this is these
culture wars they only animate
Republicans you have Democratic
candidates saying they want national
laws that allow abortion basically up to
a point of birth like New York federal
laws that do that but don't worry
Democrats are certainly not
nationalizing the abortion issue then
you have Elizabeth Warren who is
fear-mongering in the extreme she says
they're over they're going to overturn
Roe vs. Wade
Pocahontas
yeah yeah she she's she's very moving
Canada anyway
Elizabeth Warren our Native American
senator from from Oklahoma
oh no she's from Massachusetts yeah my
bad in any case Elizabeth Warren she
she's been doing these little Instagram
aoc type videos where she where she
films herself in her kitchen by the way
we need to start a petition get
Elizabeth Warren out of the kitchen get
her out of the kitchen she is a strong
powerful woman there is no reason she
needs to film herself in the kitchen
doesn't have like a dent or something
anyway Elizabeth Warren says they're
gonna overturn Roe versus Wade first of
all from her mouth to God's ears but I
really don't think this is what's going
to happen Republican men are on the
march to overturn Roe vs. Wade and with
Donald Trump stacking the courts in
favor of judges who are opposed to
abortion that could be a real
possibility women across this country
are scared
women are angry if you support women now
is the time to make that no okay this is
this crap that all women are on
Elizabeth's more inside on abortion is
just absolute sheer garbage it is not
true there's a vast divide in the female
opinion on the life vs. abortion issue
and there is a vast divide in male
opinion on the wife verses abortion
issue in fact there are certain polls
that show that women are pro-life
generally men men are but I guess
Democrats are gonna keep on riding this
horse well speaking of horses that just
won't ride apparently there are a couple
of new Democratic candidates who are
gonna jump in the race I know I'm very
excited about it you know who announced
this week you know who announced
yesterday Billiam de Blasio the mayor of
New York and grew and notorious
groundhog serial killer
[Music]
theme music for grand hog serial killer
bill de blasio so bill de blasio has
announced his candidacy and everybody is
looking at each other going why why is
that why he's a terrible mayor of New
York
he's helped just like Los Angeles or
Seattle major cities around the country
governed by Democrats that used to be
really shiny and nice now turning into
pits bill de blasio has decided he wants
to take that national so bill de blasio
unleashed an announcement video it was
not a great announcement video for
president it was more of an announcement
video for mayor he also happened to
maybe violate the law by doing this
announcement video from the back of a
city-owned vehicle which is using city
resources for campaigns here is what is
possessing Bill de Blasio to do this
other than he looks at mayor Peabody
judge and he's like that guy is the
mayor of South Bend which has like five
people and I'm the mayor of New York why
shouldn't I run for president of the
United States here's bill de blasio
silly announcement video doesn't matter
if you live in a city or a rural area a
big state a small state doesn't matter
what your ethnicity is people in every
part of this country feel stuck or even
like they're going backwards but the
rich got richer
I'm a New Yorker I've known Trump's at
bully for a long time this is not news
to me or anyone else here and I know how
to take them on as president I will take
on the wealthy I will take on the big
corporations I will not rest until this
government serves working people as
mayor of the largest city in America
I've done Donald he found this one
person in New York who attained a Blasio
for president by the way polls show that
no one in New York wants Bill DeBlasio
to run for president no one nobody even
wants him really to be mayor it's just
that he's sort of the Democrat who's
there it's really hilarious you know it
actually make a good mayor of New York
seriously aoc would make a good mayor of
New York because she's basically Bill
DeBlasio
but better at it I mean she'd suck as
mayor when I say she'd make a good mayor
of New York I mean should be a terrible
mayor but if you're gonna elect a
communist as mayor of your city you may
as well elect a Democratic Socialist of
America who puts an attractive face on
this stupidity bill de blasio the best
part of this was de Blasio announced on
GMA and Good Morning America this
morning that he was running for
president Good Morning America is filmed
in New York protesters gathered outside
the GMA studio to chant liar at him
while he was making his it's a great way
to go here's some footage of it
[Music]
outside are chanting liar as he
announces his presidential run at Good
Morning America so things are going
great for Bill DeBlasio
he though is not the only candidate who
announced yesterday that he was running
for president there's a guy named Steve
Bullock you've never heard about him no
not Bullock like the guy from Deadwood
like Steve Bullock he's the governor of
Montana nobody knows who he is and he's
in Montana which means he has like seven
constituents because Montana's a great
state but like seven people live there
in fact there are there more senatorial
seats from Montana I believe than
congressional seats and that correct or
am i screwing up my states in any case
Steve Bullock his we have a little bit
of Steve Bullock theme music I think we
will only end up playing once
unfortunately so Steve Bullock you know
really doing yeoman's working I'm
correct about this Montana only has two
senators and one representative in the
US House of Representatives like seven
people live there and he's like you know
what I'm running for president and then
he was asked an unfortunate question
Steve Bullock
please net you've been governor of the
state for seven years please name
accomplishment not like a lot of them
just like ah accomplishment one
accomplishment here's Steve Bullock
really demonstrating why he should be
President of the United States
I am happy that hopefully my kids still
know my most important job is being
their dad I think the things where you
know as governor it's not like Attorney
General and you know you won or lost a
case sometimes you won't have impacts
for years okay um so he has nothing and
he he's a great dad well that's good I
mean I'm glad he's a great dad I'm a
great dad
I don't think that that means that I'm
qualified to be President of the United
States on that basis so there's that
that's that's great
meanwhile the candidate who is just
plummeting who's just falling apart is
beta remember that time that beta was
like the romantic frontrunner remember
that time that beta was just he was
gonna be the guy right he was gonna
channel that RFK Obama energy was gonna
come out of nowhere and sweep to victory
and then it turns out that he's a giant
weirdo so beta theme music please ride
that skateboard no we're really enjoying
himself flipping those bangs had him
sent away yesterday
turned out his bangs were even too long
for beta it was like you know what brah
need a haircut so he went over to the
barbershop and then he live-streamed his
haircut because he didn't learn anything
from when he live-streamed his dental
appointment so now we're gonna get paid
out in just real life situations man we
got a feel with beta what it's like to
be beta and that means you're gonna see
him on the can it means that you're
going to see beta at his proctologist
appointment hope you're ready for that
one bra but you're also gonna see beta
get a haircut in the most Awkward
possible way yeah play it brah
getting a haircut after after being on
the road for almost two weeks or some
more connections between high schools
and unions high school students and
apprenticeships see this massage gussy
suppose those I don't even know what's
going on right now
maybe I'm ignorant about haircuts I've
never seen something like this at a
barbershop and I guess this is a thing
say he's getting some sort of some sort
of massage from the guy and the guys
standing there looking like why is this
even happening to me
he's like the dental hygienist who had
no idea why this was all happening at
one point during this haircut
appointment bado rock started talking
about his ear hair with his barber
it's like TMI dude nobody wants to be
that close to you so things getting very
awkward in the 2020 Democratic
presidential race no wonder that Joe
Biden looks like a sane person by
comparison because truly the number of
saying people in this race and now I got
Bill DeBlasio and bade oh and Cory
mcboogerballs awoke at okay time for
some things I like and then we'll do
some things that I hate so things that I
like today so yesterday I was on a plane
when I'm on a plane that means it's time
to watch a movie gang so I watched cold
pursuit now this was the movie that had
one of the great previews of all time
because the entire movie is Liam Neeson
as a snow plow driver and this created
all sorts of memes about mr. plow you
know from The Simpsons mr. plow
they really should have called the movie
mr. plow a cold pursuit is a bad name
for the movie it was in an adaptation of
a vey movie I guess from Denmark I think
and and the movie is actually kind of
hysterically good so the movie is super
politically incorrect it is very odd it
has it has almost a No Country for Old
Men it really has a Fargo feel to it it
kind of feels like Fargo and it's it's
got some
laughs out loud funny moments here's a
little bit of the trailer I'm very
honored to be named Kiko her Citizen of
the year I'm just a guy who keeps
straight of civilization I wanted when
you drive the same Road
day after day is easy to think about the
road not taken' I was lucky I picked a
good road early and I stayed I'm mister
cocksman what can I do for you it's
about your son so basically his son dies
and then he decides to take revenge on
the entire drug ring that killed the
rules but the movie it so it's pitched
as a serious revenge drama it is utterly
unserious it's actually really really
funny so this is one of the problems
with ad campaigns for films very often
well you get from the ad campaign is not
actually what the film is so if you
watch cold pursuits trailer what you get
from it is that this is going to be the
most serious it's it's basically taken
but with a snowplow that's that's what
it is that is not what the movie is at
all it's really hysterically quirky and
weird and funny there's a whole there's
a whole scene there's I don't want to
give it away but there is one scene that
is just really funny some one of the
characters is this this Native American
drug lord and he and his crew go to a
hotel and they're trying to get a room
and they walk up to the desk and the and
they don't have a reservation and the
woman behind the desk says I think you
need to I said looking here and I see
that you you don't have a reservation
and they and they look at her they look
at her like what did you just say to us
and she doesn't understand what just
happened and then they explained that in
that that according to them she said
that they should go back to the
reservation and that they will threaten
her on Yelp if she does not in fact give
them around it's a very funny thing in
any case the movie itself is is really
weird quirky and fun go check out cold
pursuit if you're into dark humor
because that's really what it is okay
time for some things that I hate
okay so the SATs were supposed to
provide an objective metric of
performance of student performance now
you can take our safety training courses
but they are only going to move you
somewhat in one direction you not gonna
move from 1100 to 1400 on the SATs just
with an SAT prep course
SATs are basically a stand-in for an IQ
test they're a soft form of an IQ test
but the problem is that SAT
distributions are not even across racial
groups and this has led to admissions
that are lower for certain groups than
for other groups now the the lowest
group is is in by biracial data is black
folks but the highest group is not white
folks in the United States by leaps and
bounds the highest group in terms of
average SAT score are asian-americans
the average asian-american in America
scores 12 23 that's the average score
anyway no one scores in national 12:23
but the the average score for asians is
12 23 that is the average for whites 11
23 for Hispanics 990 and for blacks 946
this has led the College Board to now
assign an adversity score to every
student who takes the SAT to try to
capture their social and economic
background jumping into the debate
raging of a race and class and college
admissions the new number is calculated
using 15 factors including the crime
rate and poverty levels from the
students high school and neighborhood so
in other words we're not going to look
at the individual instead we're just
gonna use Census Bureau data from the
area where you grew up and they make
assumptions about how you grew up we're
going to assume that somebody who grew
up in a richer neighborhood obviously
experienced less adversity than somebody
grew up in a poorer neighborhood we're
going to assume that based on racial
group that you experienced more
adversity than someone who's a member of
a different racial group the college
board is not releasing by the way any of
the factors that they are using the
adversity score is is not actually a
score of individual adversity is in fact
a group judgment so it is the it is the
nature of this thing to be racially
discriminatory and this will
particularly affect Asians who of course
are scoring leaps and bounds above
everybody else on the SAT the fact that
the College Board will not actually
demonstrate exactly how they come up
with this stuff is pretty incredible
now the College Board had tried this
several years back
and then it turned out that people saw
that this was just a stand-in for race
and they got uptight nonetheless the
College Board is trying it again here
quote is according to The Wall Street
Journal the College Board declined to
say how it calculates the adversity
score or ways the factors that go into
it the data that informs the score comes
from public records such as the US
Census as well as some sources
proprietary to the College Board's we're
not going to look at whether the rich
kid lost mom at age 11 from breast
cancer or whether the poor kid had a
solid two-parent family instead we're
going to look at is just the Census
Bureau data from that specific area that
is the essence of trumping individual
data with group data it is the which is
discrimination
okay I've talked about this before
Thomas solo has three types of
discrimination that he talks about one
is discrimination that is fine right
this is its you discriminate in what you
eat every night do you want a burger or
do you want a vegetarian meal that's
that's fine discrimination don't cares
about it then there is open
discrimination which is you are of a
particular race therefore you are lesser
and no matter what individual data is
presented to me then I will continue to
say that because you are of a particular
race you are lesser that is open
discrimination and then finally there is
the and then finally there is the third
type of discrimination which is what he
calls discrimination 1a which is using
group data in the absence of individual
data so I don't know anything about you
but now I have to make a call as to what
is the most probable things I know about
you from outside indicators but if I get
individual data I will trump that the
group data with the individual data
the College Board is not engaging in
discrimination 1a their discrimination
engaging in open discrimination in other
words they're not going to look at your
specific circumstance they're gonna look
at the group data and then assign you a
group in order to give or take away
points from you
Anthony Carnival is director of
Georgetown University Center on
education and the workforce he
originally worked for the College Board
he says the purpose is to get to race
without using race that is obviously the
case that is obviously the case that is
discrimination it should be illegal
discrimination on the basis of race is
illegal in the United States that's
pretty amazing stuff all right we'll be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours of content if you
want to see those additional hours you
should subscribe it daily where
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
for our Friday broadcast I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
the College Board adds a new adversity
score to the SAT grievance goes
mainstream we will examine social
justice and its opposite you know actual
justice check it out at the Michael Nolt
show